hello readers the following video
contains explicit content
well okay not in the way you're thinking
uh it doesn't contain violence
obscenity or profanity or even anything
that wouldn't appear in a g-rated movie
but it will contain explicit evidence
yes we're talking about citing evidence
in literary analysis
when you're talking about a text and
making arguments about it in order to
successfully build that argument you
must make inferences
and draw conclusions and those must be
built on the back
of evidence both explicit that is stated
in the text
or implicit or based on clues or
evidence
in the text so your responsibility is to
tie those conclusions or inferences
back to explicit or implicit evidence in
the text
it can't just be this is a feeling i
have it has to be
my feeling about this is backed up by
this specific evidence
say you're trying to make an argument in
a book that like the captain of this
pirate ship
and let's just say i guess he's a he's a
bird man that's what i drew he's a bird
man
uh is really unkind to the main
character in the beginning of the book
but changes by the end of the book and
treats everyone including the main
character with
respect and courtesy so i'm going to
write that my argument is that the
captain's behavior changes towards the
emcee the main character
i have to back that assertion up with
evidence so how do we find
those details first you have to seek out
parts of the book where the captain and
the main character interact
then look closely at the prose and
dialogue
what are the details that prove your
point which are the strongest most
specific details that say oh yes
here is where the captain is being mean
here is where the captain is being
respectful
if you can't find evidence for your
assertion
first try searching in a different part
of the book or
importantly acknowledge the possibility
that you might have a weak
argument maybe it's time to start over
and find a new or
different argument to make and find
support for
once you've assembled your evidence work
it into your analysis
captain bixby is dismissive and rude to
aniola when she first joins the crew of
the pirate ship albatross
i might say and then back it up with an
explicit example of captain bixby being
dismissive and rude
with a page number citation like so on
page 34 of to the burbling deep bigsby
says to aniola
you there what's her name these
portholes need to be scrubbed yesterday
get to work yes sir captain aniola said
but my name is does it look like i care
the captain snarled
but by the end of the story when eniola
has proven her worth
saved the day and humbled the captain he
treats her and everyone around him with
much greater respect
and deference on page 225 after bixby
tends to eniola's broken leg
he tells her aniola that was some mighty
fine pirating you did
you showed no fear when you punched that
kraken and more importantly
you showed no fear when you stood up to
me i was wrong
and i have been a jerk and i am sorry
now both of those examples use explicit
evidence where captain bixby is being a
jerk
and then when he is apologizing for
being a jerk there's also implicit
evidence too
bigsby tends to enola's broken leg so
while he's not saying
i will take care of you little buddy
with his words he is saying it with his
actions
and in that first example when he
demands that anyola clean the portholes
he's not literally saying
i'm impatient but by saying they need to
be scrubbed yesterday as in immediately
because you already messed up
he's implying that he's impatient now
there is no such book that i know of
about a kraken punching girl pirate but
if we're lucky my friend jordan will
write one
remember to use strong details to get
good evidence
you know there might be a part of to the
burbling deep where captain bixby
huffs angrily at aniola but doesn't say
anything
and that's mean or at least impolite but
it's not as strong
as him yelling at her so when you find a
detail
ask yourself how does that detail relate
back to your analysis or your argument
is it repeated does that detail or
detail similar to it
appear elsewhere in the text and if you
see a lot of similar details
how do those details prove the argument
that you're trying to make
if you have a sense of what the central
idea or ideas of the text is
try to connect those details back to
that central idea
and then connect that central idea to
your own argument
i don't know what to the burbling deep
is about because i made it up like 20
minutes ago
but maybe one theme in it is that it's
important to recognize the potential
within other people
and that's both and that can be both
true for aniola who becomes a hero and
punches a giant
octopus monster but it can also be true
of captain bixby who
occupies a kind of antagonistic role and
then changes through the story
and so we can build our argument around
that idea
that character change is possible not
just for the main character but for
everybody
so that's where i'll leave you remember
to choose the pieces of evidence that
give you the strongest support for your
idea and if the evidence doesn't match
your idea
you might need to change the idea itself
you can learn anything david out